[Music]
hi
dino here i'm with apogee and i help
people use
apis to build their digital businesses
welcome to your apogee edge trial with
apogee you'll be able to securely expose
bare apis with api keys or oauth or jwt
modernize existing soap services publish
your apis to developers through your own
custom api portal
and get visibility into usage of your
apis via
api analytics all of that is available
to you when you manage your apis with
apogee edge
listen apis are the foundation for
digital businesses
large and small and with apogee you're
ready to harness that potential for
yourself
in upcoming videos we'll get hands-on
and i'll show you how to wrap management
around your apis
in minutes before we do that let's cover
some basics
the key concept enabling the api
management goodness in apigee edge
is the api proxy a proxy is a wrapper
for your actual service
clients instead of calling your api
endpoint directly call the api proxy
and the api proxy calls your existing
api
you may be thinking why the extra hop
why use one extra moving part
well i'll tell you the api proxy
provides the way to plug in
an application independent mechanism for
you to specify consistent management
rules and policies
that apply to all of your apis your apis
might be a mix of services
lacking consistency with respect to
security or data model
or even url design and an api proxy
allows you to build a coherent facade
around those various endpoints or
maybe all of your apis are clean new
implementations
so you don't need a proxy to enforce
consistency
but you will still want an api proxy to
handle things like
oauth token verification or caching
routing rate limiting and analytics and
reporting
apigee can provide all of that with no
coding and
no modification of your existing
services so that's api management
apigee edge lets you easily add
management to any api
ready to get started in the next video
we'll dive into the first step in using
apogee
creating your first proxy till next time
keep it digital
[Music]